scared of dining alone with your cat
well here's something to add to that
fear they might eat you after you die
this surprisingly common concern is
getting attention thanks to a recent
paper out of the forensic investigation
Research Station at Colorado Mesa
University researchers there were
studying body decomposition when they
unintentionally captured footage of cats
feasting on human corpses now we would
show you the images but they're
incredibly gruesome bite marks no nobody
has to nobody should see these now those
were feral cats that wandered in from
the desert but there are also documented
cases of house cats consuming their dead
owners to find out what to make of all
this we spoke with dr. Michael Delgado a
cat behavior specialist at UC Davis so
let's get this question out of the way
if I was a cat owner and I died suddenly
will my cat eat me there's a very good
chance that your cat would eat you
assuming that your body laid around for
an extended period of time how in the
world did scientists manage to study
cats eating corpses so it's important to
understand that the researchers who
published this finding were not
specifically looking to test if cats
would eat corpses so the study was
really an observation that was made
during a separate research project
looking into the decomposition of human
bodies and so they had corpses outside
that were exposed to the elements and it
just so happened that because they had
cameras on these bodies they were able
to capture footage feral cats and us
sneaking into the facility and snacking
on some of the bodies they have fences
around so that large animals don't come
in but apparently in the fences were not
secure enough to keep cats out it's
interesting these are things that kind
of rub us the wrong way they maybe don't
fit into our schema of our pets being
loving and loving us it really kind of
violates that idea of like we do so much
for our pets and then they turn around
and eat us so I understand that there
were dozens of bodies on this research
facility but the cats tended to have a
preference can you tell me about that
yeah so in this case there
two cats that have been observed
consuming flesh of some of the corpses
and in both cases they picked an
individual body that they seemed to go
back to over and over again and it was a
different body for each cat so we don't
really know why the cats would have that
strong of a preference maybe some of the
flesh had decomposed to the extent that
it was easier to actually break into the
flesh and eat and then once that process
has been started it might just be safer
to go back to what you know I know that
I liked the taste or I didn't get sick
after I eat that particular bit of meat
which is really how we should be
thinking about this and so I decided to
kind of review the other literature
about scavenging by cats and it turned
out that there were quite a few other
reports of mostly pet owners who were
consumed not fully but you know flesh
eaten by their pets there were dozens
and they were you know mostly cakes
reports from you know police reports and
other you know incidents where where
people basically observed this behavior
happening is there any idea of like a
number how many times this has happened
I have no idea you know first of all we
have low opportunity for the behavior to
happen how many people you know died
suddenly in their home nobody checks on
them and they live with a cat so it's
not a frequently occurring behavior and
it's also possible that it happens but
it's not notice I was also a little
worried because I didn't want to
necessarily highlight something that
might promote negative ideas about cats
people already kind of think cats are
evil or plotting to kill us or just
constantly scheming to get back at us
and so I wanted to be really careful
about how this was presented to the
public because it is the kind of topic
that could really turn people against
cats like oh they just want to kill
people and eat them feeling really good
right now that I have
so scientists didn't intend to study
cats eating corpses why do you think
they continue to look into it what kind
of value are we gonna get out of that
kind of research we primarily think of
cats as predators as animals who hunt
kill and then eat what they've killed
and in this case it really highlights
the fact that they are also scavengers
so why would that be
I think one important thing to consider
is that it an animal who can hunt and
scavenge is actually increasing their
dietary repertoire so now if there's no
available animals to hunt it's possible
that you could increase your
reproductive Fitness in other words your
ability to pass on your genes by being
adaptive by being able to eat animals
that have been killed by someone else
that you can now take advantage of and
this is something that again we don't
really think of it as being common among
cats although it's definitely documented
some of the scientific literature that
cats will scavenge but it's definitely
much less than other animals like
ferrets and dogs who are big time
scavengers wait did she say dogs no no
no no there is no way my sweet girl
would ever consider eating me there's
actually been more documentation of dogs
eating their owners than cats no don't
blame it on the cats I think it's
difficult for humans to kind of set
aside our morals and our kind of
feelings about people or animals that
are important to us
most of us would never think about
eating our pet even if they died and I
think we tend to hold our companion
animals maybe to a high moral standard
that's really based in human beliefs and
ethics and doesn't really have much to
do with their reality at the end of the
day if they're hungry and there's flesh
around they are going to be
opportunistic and take advantage of
what's available so it's really
important not to kind of think of this
as oh your cat's plotting to kill you or
cats are evil the instinct to do what is
necessary to survive is very strong and
that includes eating whatever is
available
so the Katsina study were feral cats
what does that tell us about the
difference between feral cats and
domesticated cats so domesticated cats
and feral cats are both cats there's no
clear genetic difference between the two
so in the case of the current study it's
possible that these cats did not have
any other food source aside from what
they were able to hunt so in that case
they might have been a little more
motivated to scavenge because they were
hungry so is it safe to say that we
would see a little bit less of this
behavior out of domesticated cats in a
home that provides food you would
anticipate them fewer of those cats
would eat their dead owner however some
of the case reports that I reviewed
suggested that there was one dog who had
freely available food he actually had
food in his stomach and he still did
consume part of his owner so there may
be other motivating factors what was
actually theorized in one paper was that
what might happen is not that the animal
just starts eating the person but that
they don't recognize that the person is
dead at first and so they might start
buying or even nipping at the owners
body because they think that the owner
should respond to them so they're kind
of trying to get some reaction from the
owner and then from that they might tear
into the flesh and that might start a
little cascade of the snacking so while
I would think that that would reduce the
likelihood of scavenging we don't know
we don't have enough evidence to say it
would stop it altogether
so because of ethical issues there
hasn't been a specific study on it but
we do have mounting evidence that
animals can or will eat their dead owner
so it's not like cats are eating people
left and right it really has to be kind
of a perfect storm of circumstances
which is typically that you have someone
who lives alone in an isolated situation
they have an illness that might lead
them to die suddenly and they live with
a pet who's freely moving around in
their home so that's the conditions that
tend to lead to a pet indulging I guess
or eating parts of their owners bodies
and the other thing that's important to
recognize is that just
because animals will eat part of a
corpse does not mean that they will eat
you when you're alive there's little
risk to a living person if your animal
does not have aggression issues to think
that they're going to try to eat you or
kill you while you're still living I
think this captures people's attention
because people really don't understand
cats very well and so they tend to
interpret their behaviors may be in
negative or malicious ways so they think
that maybe their cats plotting revenge
on them for taking that vacation or
because they don't like their new
boyfriend and so people really project a
lot of emotional states onto their cats
their cat is probably not really going
through and I think to an extent again
there's this kind of morbid fascination
and maybe some people actually like the
idea that their cat might eat them after
they die a lot of people that have
talked about this have said you know if
it helps my cat survive I don't care
I'll be dead so perhaps some people take
a little pride in the naughtiness of
cats or this idea that cats because
they're perceived as somehow less
trainable or less loyal than dogs that
they're automatically going to do
something that maybe to us seems
terrible like eating bodies I would just
like to emphasize that again this
research as fascinating as it is doesn't
mean that we can tell if any particular
cat is going to eat an individual
doesn't mean that most cats will do this
it's been observed but it could be just
that the circumstances have to be pretty
extreme for this behavior to come up so
it's been great and a little creepy
chatting with you thanks so much for
joining us today
thank you so much for having me
you